all righty then it's time for drew's
news your daily pop pop pop of the good
news bubble wrap and with me at the desk
my little bubblicious effervescent
co-pilot ross
[Applause]
matthews that is so satisfying with the
bubble wrap yeah i'm still doing i'm 42
years old you guys still do it when you
get that bubble wrap
satisfying um well make sure you stick
around to the end of the show
because
we have another blood pumping round of
pop quiz
that's right pay attention everyone
because one lucky member of our audience
is gonna be put to the test we'll ask
you three questions about today's show
and if you get it right you're gonna win
a thousand dollars
we're gonna give it away
just give it away yeah
i know i'm so excited i love when people
win okay first up we've got people's
latest cover boy
oh no here it is here we go
it's stanley tucci
yeah there's an interview where stanley
talks about beating cancer and how his
friends and his wife felicity got him
through it and he talks about being a
sex symbol at age 61 he says it's so
wonderful he says i don't quite get it
but i'm very glad and people want a
hoochie coochie with the tucci and how
cool they're like at 61 stanley tucci is
now a sex symbol and you know what that
means you guys in like 20 years you're
all gonna be fantasizing about this okay
i have i'm telling you we already are
trend alert
stay tuned all right hey next up we all
know the brits love their high tea right
but it was an american who just managed
to host the highest high tea on record
listen to this cnn travel reports andrew
hughes hosted a tea party at the very
tippy top of mount everest yeah the tn
cookies at 21
312 feet he said he missed his climbing
community so much during the pandemic
they swore that when they could get back
together they'd do something special so
he decided tea on the mountaintop and he
even managed to haul girl scout cookies
all the way from seattle he purchased
them from the girl scout troupe 6000 the
troop that serves young girls right here
in new york city's shelter system yeah i
mean
the top
of mount everest
i read this story that he had t at the
top of mount everest and you know what i
thought about what me last weekend in a
hotel uber eats ordering starbucks
because i was too lazy to even get out
of my hotel room and then oh is it this
man's at the top of mount everest i know
i love also like the question of would
you climb everest for a thin mint
i love it me too all right well next up
we've got a brand new food holiday
coming to new york city this sunday it's
today's food news
all right this story is very personal
for me
veg news reports that new york is
joining 40 other cities and states
declaring march 20th meet out day so to
celebrate you just drop the meat for one
day and explore the awesome world of
plant-based foods out there the holiday
was declared by mayor eric adams who is
also responsible and this was news to me
making mondays meatless at all 1
700 public schools in new york city i
didn't know that yes that's very cool
that's a revelation and a revolution
and you know what here to celebrate our
own meatless menu please welcome all the
way from corn headquarters my best
friend chicken
[Applause]
oh my gosh what'd you bring oh my gosh
chicken this is my best friend everybody
we just did a commercial together and um
and uh we are best friends and we're go
yeah that's our commercial right now oh
look at you
there we are
chicken are you excited about meat out
day
oh
i am too
care chicken
oh i want one
and that's the line at the end of our
commercial because you wouldn't eat your
best friend
oh these are corns meatless nuggets
and i'm actually their cmo chief mom
officer but i'm a partner now there
because i believe so much
in their product drew i'm sold
get your own
oh my gosh
[Music]
you